NOW BECAUSE OF CHINA’S ACTIONS
THOUSANDS AROUND THE WORLD ARE
DEAD, MILLIONS OTHERS ARE
SUFFERING, AND CHINA MUST BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
HERE WITH A LOT MORE ON THIS,
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO.
MR. SECRETARY, GREAT TO SEE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
YOU ACTUALLY BROUGHT IN CHINESE
REPRESENTATIVES TO YOUR OFFICE
ON THIS VERY TOPIC OF BLAMING
THE U.S. MILITARY AND OTHER
ISSUES.
CAN YOU BRING US INSIDE THAT
CONVERSATION?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON
TONIGHT.
WE DID IN FACT CALL THE CHINESE
AMBASSADOR AND I SPOKE TO MY
COUNTERPART IN CHINA A COUPLE
DAYS BACK.
THIS DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN,
WHICH BEGAN WHEN WE BEGAN TO
CALL OUT THIS RISK THAT WAS
CREATED NOT ONLY FOR THE CHINESE
PEOPLE BUT NOW PEOPLE ALL ACROSS
THE WORLD, WHERE THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT KNEW ABOUT THIS RISK,
HAD IDENTIFIED IT, THEY WERE THE
FIRST TO KNOW AND THEY WASTED
VALUABLE DAYS AT THE FRONT AND,
ALLOWING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE TO LEAVE WE WANT TO GO
TO PLACES LIKE ITALY, THAT IS
NOW SUFFERING SO BADLY.
THEY TRIED TO SUPPRESS THIS
INFORMATION.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE MEANS BY
WHICH THEY DID IT.
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO DO THE WORK
TO SUPPRESS THE VIRUS, WHICH IS
WHAT THE WORLD DEMANDED, THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY DIDN’T
GET IT RIGHT AND PUT COUNTLESS
LIVES AT RISK AS A RESULT OF
THAT.
>> Sean: MR. SECRETARY, DO YOU
BELIEVE NOW THAT THE
INFORMATION, WHICH COULD BE
VALUABLE TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD -- WE CAN GET INFORMATION
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL AT THIS
POINT.
YOU BELIEVE THAT INFORMATION IS
ACCURATE THAT THEY ARE SENDING
OVER NOW?
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE HAD AN INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT TIME GETTING
PROFESSIONAL MEDICAL PEOPLE IN.
YOU WILL RECALL EARLY ON, WE
OFFERED TO HAVE AMERICA’S FINEST
EXPERTS TO TRAVEL THERE AND
ASSIST THEM, SINCE THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
WE WEREN’T PERMITTED IN.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
HAS DONE THAT UP WITH THE WORLD
IN THE WORLD’S PEOPLE AT RISK.
THEY HAVEN’T BEEN SUFFICIENTLY
TRANSPARENT AND THE RISK YOU
FIND IF WE DON’T GET THIS RIGHT,
IF WE DON’T GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS, IS THIS COULD BE SOMETHING
THAT IS REPEATABLE.
MAYBE NOT IN THIS FORM, MAYBE
NOT ON THIS WAY, BUT
TRANSPARENCY MATTERS.
THAT IS WHY WHEN WE SEE THEM
FORCING JOURNALISTS OUT, WHEN WE
SEE PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THIS,
PEOPLE NO LONGER HAVING ACCESS
TO THE INTERNET, NO LONGER ABLE
TO SPEAK OPENLY AND FREELY,
THOSE RISKS, THOSE QUESTIONS.
AS AMERICA’S MOST SENIOR
DIPLOMAT, WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO MAKE SURE WE TRY AND GET THIS
INFORMATION FROM THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY SO WE CAN HELP
OUR MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES GET THIS
RIGHT AND SAVE LIVES FOR
AMERICANS AND PEOPLE ALL ACROSS
THE WORLD.
>> Sean: MR. SECRETARY, WE’VE
KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR MANY YEARS.
IF MY MEMORY SERVES ME WELL I
THINK YOU GRADUATED ONE IN YOUR
CLASS AT HARVARD.
I’M NOT SURE, I’M PRETTY SURE
YOU WERE RIGHT UP THERE.
IF THE CHINESE SAID TO YOU EARLY
ON AND SAID, HEY, WE HAVE A
PROBLEM.
HOW QUICKLY WOULD YOU HAVE ACTED
TO MOBILIZE AMERICA’S BEST,
GREATEST MEDICAL RESEARCHERS,
SCIENTISTS, DR. FAUCIS OF THE
WORLD, TO IMMEDIATELY ASSIST
THEM IN WHATEVER PROBLEMS THEY
WERE HAVE?
>> I DIDN’T QUITE GRADUATED
FIRST IN MY CLASS.
I WAS A GOOD ENOUGH STUDENT.
>> Sean: ONE OR TWO, I KNOW
IT’S UP THERE.
>> [LAUGHS]
WE WOULD’VE RESPONDED
IMMEDIATELY.
ALL OF THE EXPERTS, FROM THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR
WANTED ACCESS TO ALL OF THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE STRUCTURE
OF THIS VIRUS, ALL OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WOULD’VE
PERMITTED US NOT ONLY TO START
ON MITIGATION AND CURES AND
VACCINES, BUT ALSO IT ALLOWED US
TO IDENTIFY THE WAY THAT THE
VIRUS SPREADS AND TO BEGIN TO
TAKE THE ACTION THAT COULD’VE
KEPT THIS VIRUS IN A PLACE WHERE
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO KEEP IT SO FAR.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU, I
READ COMMENTS YOU MADE ABOUT THE
IRRADIANCE.
YOU KNOW I’M NOT A BIG FAN OF
IRAN, OR RUSSIA, OR CHINA.
BUT PUTTING THAT ASIDE, IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL IF WE COULD HELP
THEM.
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THAT AND I
KEEP HEARING ABOUT THESE
AMERICANS ON A MISSION TRIP THAT
ARE LOCKED DOWN IN PERU AND I
BELIEVE YOUR OFFICE HAS BEEN
ACTIVE IN TRYING TO GET THEM
HOME SAFELY.
>> LET ME TAKE THE SECOND ONE
FIRST.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROTECT
AMERICAN CITIZENS ALL ACROSS THE
WORLD.
WE KNOW STUDENTS THAT ARE IN
PERU.
SOME OTHER TRAVELERS THAT ARE
THERE AS WELL.
OTHER COUNTRIES TOO THAT HAVE
SHUT DOWN THEIR AIRPORTS, WE ARE
WORKING TO TRY TO SOLVE PROBLEMS
FOR EACH OF THOSE AMERICAN
CITIZENS, AND WE’VE JUST LEARNED
ABOUT THEM OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF DAYS, BUT KNOW THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE CLEAR
THAT WE ARE GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO GET EVERY
AMERICAN HOME SAFELY.
AS FOR IRAN, THE SAME TRUE FOR
NORTH KOREA, THESE ARE COUNTRIES
THAT WE HAVE DEEP DIFFERENCES
WITH.
WE ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
CREATE BETTER CONDITIONS FOR
THEIR PEOPLE AND PART OF THAT IS
MAKING SURE WERE AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDE HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE
WHEN WE CAN.
WE’VE OFFERED TO TO THE
NORTH KOREANS AS WELL AS TO THE
IRANIAN PEOPLE.
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE, AND
WE’VE OFFERED TO FACILITATE
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE COMING
INTO THOSE COUNTRIES FROM U.N.
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER
COUNTRIES AS WELL.
WE WILL KEEP DOING THAT, IT’S
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IN A TIME